these mingled with witches and of battle
with vampires it's clear that the last
Kingdom's Alexander Draymond has a nag
for spellbinding spectacle Netflix's 9th
century costume drama the last kingdom
was adopted from the successful Saxon
Story series of historical Adventure
novels from renowned English author
Bernard Cornwell originally produced by
bbc2 in the UK and BBC America in the US
Netflix became the sole producer of the
series from season three onward stepping
up to foot the show's substantial Bill
the books and show follows the exploits
of utread of bebenba the dispossessed
Scion of a Noble House in the ancient
English Kingdom of northumbria the Saxon
stories book series currently since the
13 entries with a final installment
hitting shelves back in 2020 this proved
fortunate for Netflix as the last
Kingdom adapted Cornwell's books at a
respectable Pace chewinged up about two
novels per season I gave you glory
I gave you the freedom to worship your
God and still you treat me no better
than a hound
every thread is played by Alexander
Draymond and if you think his handsome
Visage looks familiar that's a very good
reason according to IMDb Alexander
Draymond was born in Germany although he
lived for some time in France and moved
to England to study at the prestigious
Drama Center London which permanently
closed its doors in 2022. he earns his
thespian Stripes performing on the stage
in both Paris and London before making
the jump to television and film
draymond's first major role in American
television was as a recurring character
on the third season of the popular
American Horror Story Anthology series
Draymond played the part of Luke Ramsey
appearing on five episodes of the witchy
common storyline the son of the
Christian Joan Ramsey played by Patty
LuPone who lives next door to miss Roby
shows Academy Luke mixes in with the
Witcher studying and living there
however his religious beliefs cause him
a great deal of inner turmoil in the end
after getting literally stabbed in the
back shot through the head and put into
a coma Luke is murdered by his mother
which follows his realization that she
killed Luke's father God told me you put
the beef in the car
he knew dad was allergic to bees you
knew you'd get away with it the role of
Luke Ramsey introduced a clean shaven
Draymond to American audiences and made
it abundantly clear that the actor had
both the talent and Charisma to continue
his Ascent into becoming a leading man
for any size screen it wasn't long after
his American Horror Story debut that
Draymond really began exploring the
world of feature films one year before
he was casting the leading role of
utread on the last Kingdom and one year
following his turn on American Horror
Story Draymond starred in the vampire
romance Thriller blood Ransom he'd
played the part of Jeremiah heading up a
cast that also included Clifton Powell
Jamie Harris and Emily Skinner Draymond
seemingly proved his ability to hold an
entire production on his ample's
shoulders because it wasn't long after
blood Ransom that he was snatched up by
the producers of the last Kingdom don't
be afraid
or not
why would Raymond continue to
demonstrate his range by appearing in
two more feature-length films the 2016
mystery guys reading poems and the 2019
romantic crime drama hot luck he was
already an established name with a busy
production schedule thanks to the
success of the lost kingdom now the
future's looking bright for Draymond who
recently appeared in the Swedish
Thriller horizon line the film also
stars get out actress Alison Williams
with whom in reality Draymond shares a
son and is romantically engaged as
utread is founder for minding us Destiny
is all and it certainly seems like
Draymond was destined for stardom from
the beginning
[Music]
foreign